100.000 millones de euros en dos años
plan de galones este paquete de estímulo
está diseñado para asegurar que la
economía no se colapse se fundó para
sumar sextos para el plan reactivación
de francia se construye sobre tres
pilares primero la transición ecológica
el gobierno quiere una economía más
verde se invertirán 30.000 millones de
euros en ella plan sobre uso de
bicicletas inversiones en movilidad
verde e hidrógeno apoyo a la renovación
térmica de los edificios algo que el
gobierno espera que lleve a 160 mil
empleos creados hasta 2021
para esto las empresas recibirán ayuda y
es el segundo pilar la soberanía
económica el objetivo reubicar a empleos
en francia en sectores estratégicos como
la alta tecnología o la salud la
dotación es de 35 mil millones de euros
es decir una reducción de los impuestos
sobre la producción y una ayuda a las
empresas endeudadas después de la crisis
sanitaria y por eso el tercer pilar es
la cohesión social y territorial 35 mil
millones de euros financiarán el
personal de la salud y las medidas para
el empleo de los jóvenes
también se revisará la estrategia de
reducción de la pobreza de nada para la
primera línea los cajeros los empleados
de tiendas la otra crítica es que el
plan llega demasiado tarde no se votara
sino hasta el final del año en el marco
de la ley de finanzas 2021